lupita nyong'o stuns and sings at the
jungle book premiere look for the bare
necessities the simple bare necessities
forget about your worries and you strive
the actress turned heads on Monday at
the le premier of the jungle book
keeping the theme alive in this chic and
a sparkly ensemble well this is
custom-made j.crew and I just love it
you know we went with the with the theme
jungle book from the fitted a lime green
top to that shimmering a fringe skirt
the 33 year old proved at once again as
she's the queen of red carpet style
Lupita plays Raksha in the new Disney
reboot and she gushed to et about why
she was so excited to join the cast I
just remember Jungle Book was definitely
a part of my childhood I just absolutely
loved that world and a part of me
thought that I ought to live there and
so it's really nice to have a chance to
be in the jungle book you know and and
be a part of the jungle and it wouldn't
be a true Disney premiere without a
little song Lupita join Katy's Cameron
Mathison for an adorable rendition of
the bare necessities I mean the bare
necessities all mother nature recipes
that bring the bare necessities of life